what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg and John here today
what did we just watch John we just
watched Guardians of the Galaxy
the first one no volume three you just
watched Gardens gossip on three right
through those doors right there here's
what I'm gonna ask you guys to do up
front please go ahead and leave a like
because we always risk getting kicked
out of the what's happened several times
got a lot of feelings and thoughts on
this one and before watching it uh the
journey over the past week has been I
watched Guardians of the Galaxy one
again I rewatched Guardians 2. and
honestly Guardians 2 went up a lot in my
book since the last time I talked to
death about a recent livestream at David
koi and then I watched I I am Groot and
I watch Infinity war end game and the
holiday special because I just wanted
like the complete package and to see how
this story of the Guardians really does
conclude I am sad to say bye to them so
with that in mind we got a special
sponsor for today's video that's also
really going to come in handy because
right now Vimeo is charging us a ton at
our patreon right now so we're gonna
roll this out real quick thank you to
Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy for
sponsoring this video because I was
ecstatic to shout them out and you want
to know why
I already owned the game within the
first week of getting my PS5 a friend of
my wife and I gifted us with this video
game so it was literally the very first
game I played on the PlayStation 5 and
it's a genuine blast do keep in mind the
game is also available on Xbox consoles
and PC now I have said it many times
right here on this very Channel
Guardians of the Galaxy is one of my
all-time favorite MCU movies so like
many of you I am sad to see it ending
with volume 3. however if you want to
keep the adventure going with the
Guardians this game is genuinely a great
way to keep that feeling alive it's a
single player story driven action
adventure game but it also won best
narrative at the game awards in 2021 so
you know what's good now I'm guilty of
not having read the Guardians Comics
only seen the movies so this was a
unique way to live in the cosmic comic
book world with the team while getting
familiar but different shades of them
throughout the Adventure Learn to work
together and you know of course help
save the Galaxy along the way and
something that I really wanted to
mention to you guys is that while you
play a Star-Lord vast majority of the
game you actually play alongside the
other guy Guardians as well so with that
there's this massive amount of back and
forth dialogue that is present for what
I think is like the almost the entirety
of the game which makes it feel all the
more lived in especially because
everyone has such a unique distinct
voice and all the Voice work is also
great and a lot of the time you get
dialogue choices on which way you want
to take the conversation so it makes for
a lot of fun role-playing but sometimes
it actually makes an impact on a
decision from a guardian later on
another thing I really want to make
clear too is that while you can upgrade
your abilities as Star-Lord as you go
along you also play alongside the other
Guardians so while you're playing you
can actually upgrade their abilities as
well and instruct them to use them on
command the worlds are really cool they
have a lot of great outfits for the
Guardians inspired by the comics and the
MCU as well the creature designs are as
cosmically weird and welcoming as you'd
hoped for and the story itself is a lot
of fun but like you'd want it also has a
lot of heart and oh yeah the soundtrack
they have this amazing soundtrack it's
fantastic epic orchestral score to
classic 80s rock tracks and they have an
original Rock album created just for
this game so yeah guys this game gets a
very high glowing recommendation for me
if you're interested you can go ahead
hit up our Link in the description box
and pin comment thank you again for
sponsoring this video
alright so if you've seen the trailers
regards the Galaxy 3 they actually
really don't give away what the plot of
the movie is so we're not going to give
away what the exact plot of the film is
but you get some teases of it involving
high evolutionary as this person who is
the one responsible for creating rocket
you get a sense of a lot of peril and
danger throughout but you also get a
sense that the movie will probably be
very emotional a lot more in that
department than the previous two
Guardians films look I'm going to keep
it real simple and straightforward for
you guys we are going to be doing a live
stream spoiler talk most of what I want
to say is gonna be reserved for that
discussion because there is so much in
here so much so much in here that I
don't want to ruin for anyone or even
really allude to honestly because they
don't even give away with the exact plot
of the movie is but the exact plot is a
very personal plot I thought this was
the exact film it needed to be I thought
it was a perfect conclusion where would
I rank it I have no no idea where I
would rank it just yet I thought this
was a strong film that just got better
as it kept going does it have a couple
of spots that I I wonder if they would
get worse or better in a re-watch maybe
that is not my takeaway with this movie
right now I have left this movie feeling
content I feel content with what
happened here I just feel like at ease
with knowing like wow I I really love
this film going to a little bit more
specifics but what are your quick
thoughts John yeah I know I'm I'm left
with a similar feeling kind of kind of
the blend of catharsis you get after a
good cry a good laugh and a fight
propulsive and there is so much to talk
about but to me it was just a grand and
emotional cathartic and and really
propulsive experience like they they
really hit the ground running and
anything I you know might have griped
about in part two like you said got
better for me there and here I thought
it builds really well on top of
everything that has come before it used
all the history yeah I didn't even know
quite what I wanted or expected going
into this but coming out of it I think
they really achieved something special
and it is two James Gunn's credit he
really does seem like one of the few MCU
directors who is able to like transcend
and put his own unique stamp on
something there's like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe then there's James
Gunn's movies yeah right and they have
their own visual Flint like they fit
into but they have their own visual
Flair their own tone their own humor
their own style and he definitely got to
strut his weird Aesthetics all over them
and he goes darker this time gets bold
with the way they execute things one
thing I really want to say John do it
something that you don't really feel a
lot in some of these Marvel properties
as of late yeah there are some real
stakes in tension here 100 there's
there's quite a few like it really earns
the Applause because they get you
wrapped up in the harrowing aspect of
these things oh my God who's gonna die
what's gonna happen like it just it just
keeps you going the whole time the lives
really feel at stake in this movie in a
way that is very satisfying to me the
standout performers they're all so good
in this they're all it's hard to start
with one good uh like they all get a
chance to shine but Rocket Raccoon and
Star-Lord would be the highlights for me
like it's it's their films more than
anyone else is here I don't want that to
sound like the other ones don't get a
chance to shine no cause The Supporting
Cast is so strong in doing what they're
there to do like from watching the
holiday special and the fact that they
carry over mantis and drax's
relationship into here and then explore
that even more and get more later
semantics I thought was excellent but
rocket you truly get his origin in this
movie you know you've probably seen some
social media reactions there is such a
tragedy to his backstory there is so
much life and nuance and the movie has a
lot of body horror but it's a lot but in
the kind of body horror that I like the
most which is not like oh look how gross
it is body Horror in the sense of like
an emotionally tragic way it serves the
characters and the themes so much uh but
I mean there's a couple of moments like
wow that's graphic it reminded me of
photographer I was like I can't believe
they put that in this movie yeah it's
lucky that we're in a Sci-Fi world with
all that stuff but it reminded me of
freaks at times in that way where the
point is you're seeing something and
you're initially supposed to recoil but
then you'd see the person inside of the
Visage yeah that's another place for the
imagination for the design to go crazy
but also ways to strike you like you
said emotionally it's interesting like
we're in Phase five now so much of phase
four dealt with overcoming trauma and
overcome and dealing with grief and this
movie carries that but in a very unique
way especially through the lens of
rocket and Star-Lord Chris Pratt give
his best work here out of any of the
Guardians movies as much as he was kind
of like a little bit of like a doofus
and lost some of the coolness as it kind
of went he's powerful in this movie he
is really really good like this movie
reminded me of like oh yeah
this is what makes him a star see that's
been I don't mean no pun intended
literally I mean like in the Celebrity
Status to Chris prattley they dial back
a lot of that doofus stuff and really
cool and dramatically engaging he gives
a powerful performance here I go back
and forth on him sometimes it's just a
Hollywood personality but re-watching
the first one I was like man this is the
Chris Pratt I really like and now
watching this one I was like this is
that but also yeah with all the weight
and emotion and the maturity that the
characters had to go through over this
journey and he really carries that in a
way that doesn't like overshadow
everything but it is impressive and it
is touching and they don't undermine it
with humor you really see him at like
how he has become a leader Adam Warlock
as seen in the trailer here he's got a
great introduction it would be a spoiler
for me to tell you what they do with him
I really think as a matter of fact we
bumped into a couple of people
who our first time meeting them there's
the first thing they brought up with us
I think there will be some debates on
the handling of Adam Warlock overall I
did like him there are a couple of
things where I'm like this is great and
works for the Guardians movie I wonder
how people will overall react for people
who know or are aware of Adam or come
into the movie for Adam yeah like it
works great for guardians but there are
some choices that they make where I go
huh I wonder how that's going to overall
go down with people yeah for sure but
Will Poulter still does a great job
regardless well Poulter still shows up
his introduction is really really strong
yeah uh very very menacing and
intimidating you're like God damn and
one of the top things I was hearing when
the movie was done other than a bunch of
Tears around me which was kind of
happening throughout the film oh I feel
like this is a weird thing to say is a
relief to hear a bunch of people talking
about the VFX are awesome in this movie
yes they are fantastic VFX
cinematography is excellent in fact I
don't want to go into any details about
what the fight scene entails but it
might have one of my favorite fight
scenes I've seen in all of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it was like an
unexpected fight that happened yes and
it was an important fight too but when
it happens I was like wow this is real
it earned a really awesome Applause and
yeah we did go to the premiere for this
one normally we don't go to the
premieres for them I'm often kind of
wary about crowd influence especially
I've seen that's affect previous reviews
for I wanted to experience with the
crowd but I'll say like this crowd was
for the most part actually not a
cheering crowd like we were wrapped with
attention it was one of those movies
where like does it have jokes yeah it's
got the jokes at the same time I wasn't
even really laughing a lot but I don't
mean that in an insulting way I was just
so like transported during my experience
with this movie A jokes would happen or
I would just be in my head going
that's a funny joke that's so funny
Marvel humor problems it just feel just
feel like how the characters all talk
and the way they acknowledge some of the
humor of previous films like a lot of
people have complained about Drax and
how they just really dumbed them up they
really acknowledge that I really feel
like James Gunn has listened and attuned
and I really think it is a perfect
conclusion to it all again great
soundtracks choices terrific sounds
perfect soundtrack choices uh nebula
Karen gillen's best work absolutely
and not not of all time I would say but
out of playing nebula yeah I
I want to go into specifics I do uh but
I'm refraining from it what I want to
just communicate to you guys is really
just the emotion I feel right now which
is It's A Beautiful film guys it's it's
beautiful on the outside also just what
it's got going on underneath the surface
It's A Beautiful film well yeah it
carries on those themes from phase four
of the trauma and of the messiness but
it also kind of arcs into a certain kind
of closure and a certain kind of
acceptance and a stepping into healing
in a way I know people will debate but I
thought a very striking and a very uh
just compelling villain in the high
evolutionary and all that comes with him
is so unhinged but in a way where you
completely feel the reality of who the
character is though he'd be you know
Larger than Life yeah I would say that
there are times where I felt that it
would occasionally go to too much of
like it just yells a lot sometimes it
kind of comes across that way like I I
wonder if it'll still feel that way to
me on a re-watch but there were times
where it was okay I kind of feel like a
lot of what you're giving this guy to do
is just really just yell there yeah
there's certainly that maniacal like my
Creations blah blah but I thought he
handled that well and they do something
different with the like At first as the
movie's going you're kind of going is
this going down to the generic path you
kind of expect to do there are certain
turns and moments that yeah are
predictable but I think what you said
about the word catharsis is so important
because it earns the moments of still
getting that release you might run into
a predictable moment however the journey
to that moment is so rich and there's
something to be said for the moment of
anticipation and then impact because you
want that moment to play out not you'll
feel slighted if it does but they still
do things with high evolutionary that I
was not expecting that I was really
impressed by how they decided to
challenge against what you might
normally expect the route to go I would
not say it is cliche they do take some
chances and that's why I would say that
there are some really bold moves of what
they do with him God I kind of feel like
Bradley Cooper should get an ostrich
even though
really Mr nominate people going back to
him their performances all around if
there's something that we a subject that
we missed to talk about apologies it's
just a special camp for the guardian I I
feel like the Guardians of the Galaxy
franchise is something truly special
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe
even for how they carry over an Infinity
war and game and and also Gamora my God
we cannot like as always said to the
billions Club so we stopped on Zoe
Saldana I love the fact of how James
Gunn really respected that this was a
different Gamora from endgame
specifically dealing with who was Gamora
at the time they plucked her out of
there in end game and who would she be
today the choices they make with her
character to be more on the just to be a
different aggressive side to put it
lightly it makes it's a great sci-fi
device because it makes very much sense
how and why she is how she is how she
fits into this version of the Guardians
but also how she clashes with them yeah
and then her and she has such a presence
like oh God yeah her and starler have
great chemistry again she's Fierce like
when she's with him they have great like
you know friction but but when she's on
her own she's just like Fierce and a
force they managed to create something
that to me feels like it really managed
to fuse the unique aspects of the first
one the unique aspects of the second one
adding its own thing to this but it
feels like a complete hole that grew out
of you know what came before it and
Groot is lovely too Groot has a lot of
really great moments in this as well
Groot has a moment in here
that people are gonna be
talking about you know even little
smaller characters like fraglin and
Cosmo the space dog like there's so many
well utilized great interesting little
additions that have grown again across
this familial Katamari that is the
franchise so here's what I'll say guys
um on my first time viewing this right
out of the theater I'm like a 98 sure
yeah like a 98 I want to re-watch it to
kind of get my feelings uh real clear on
a couple of things that I'm still unsure
how I feel about but for the most part
yeah that's striking amazing and the
iMac shots whoa
um we didn't even watch that a real IMAX
but it stands out oh no yeah you can
still tell when it's like switching to
the IMAX cameras the scope plus the way
they use so many wide-angle lenses for
all of these which you know are affects
heavy shots and and crazy maneuver like
it is in the age of huge visual effects
it still feels like movie Magic I love
it John loves it love it
gonna watch it at least Thrice me at
least two more times in the theaters I
just gotta I gotta leave us down your
thoughts Below on who's your favorite
guardian or what you're expecting this
movie or if you happen to see it what'd
you think talk with y'all soon
[Music]